a woman in a man's world that's what I
feel like in Germany's main financial
hub Frankfurt the boardrooms of the
country's big banks and other
corporations are practically all male
domains why so few women it's a similar
scenario at this pharmaceutical giant
based in Dunst at Merck is a DEXA listed
pharmaceutical company and today we're
going to meet one of the few women who
have made it to the top of German
management her name is Abby Lennon
giriko she is 56 years old comes from
Spain like me and has an impressive
track record you want to meet her come
with me
[Music]
what is her formula for being successful
I never give up never give up everything
is possible that's my philosophy no
Sofia villain guru who seems feta
nations type after graduating from high
school she was denied a place to study
medicine at college she challenged the
decision and one and then initially
became a practicing doctor what
experiences as a doctor were valuable
for your current line of work Liza I'm
both a manager and a doctor Christian
then we examine the symptoms exhibited
by the company where can we sell our
products can we increase our profits
there but we also conduct analyses to
determine the cause of particular
problems and the changes that need to be
made and that's the really exciting part
Gary who now serves a different kind of
patient but her fundamental approach is
the same she joined merrick 6 years ago
where the company was in trouble and
worked her way up to the executive part
reserves debts any other differences
between larger and smaller companies
concerning equal opportunities for women
and women taking more seriously at
bigger companies DOMA Serio al trabajo
de una mujer con Agra gay that's always
determined at the board level promoting
women's talents
is my bread-and-butter preoccupation
diarrhea comment on Desiro Gondo talent
of immense diversity puts us at a
competitive advantage which will in turn
mean better results
dinero mejor de resultados she says
being the boss means a lot of work and
networking for bailing Gary hoe that
also includes personal meetings with
important politicians she once had a
women to follow her example and gain
more confidence si la pregunta if I ask
50 men about their ambitions they'll say
I want to become a director if I ask 50
women hardly any would give that answer
casi ninguna a as marijuana Melo Anaya
Theo Sam if you'd asked me 15 years ago
I wouldn't have said that either it's
that movie it's okay to say you want to
become a boss of a big firm I have to
encourage women to have those ambitions
because women tend to be more timid la
mujeres mucho mas timid ahora
lingaraju is in charge of a staff of
20,000 in the company's health care
division but to this day have fashion
choices and the height of her heels
still make more headlines than her
business record noise we infrequent in
interviews I often get asked how I
divide up my time between professional
and private matters they wouldn't ask a
man in my position that estrada
bestseller pregunta on baron kk
occupying position these are stereotypes
that only future generations will be
able to overcome not a [ __ ] who steady
never signal have to grown-up daughters
do you think they will have an easier
time than you did on the job market los
hombres y las mujeres en el mercado
Laboral yo que sera I do believe they
will be less of an impediment to
themselves the new generation are no
longer conditioned to take care of the
family first because they were brought
up differently I mean okay but I am
concerned about them having to make
drastic decisions I'm even worried about
whether or not I'll ever have
grandchildren billing gerricault would
love to see her daughters combine a
career with children the way she did but
the working world will have to evolve a
lot more before that become standard
[Music]